Aaron Carter splits from girlfriend
Madison Parker reveals he found boys and
girls attractive at a young age she can
exclusively confirm the 29 year old
singer and his photographer girlfriend
called it quits
last week met on Instagram a source
tells ET the breakup was very amicable
and Aaron is continuing to focus on his
personal self with regards to his truth
health and music the former pair sat
down with et just last month where they
opened up about their future together I
want to be married I want to be engaged
to my beautiful girlfriend in medicine I
want to be a good father a good role
model a strong role model the news of
the split comes after Aaron opened up in
a message to fans on Twitter about his
sexuality writing when I was around 13
years old I started to find boys and
girls attractive Aaron went on to say he
had an experience with a male he'd grown
up and worked with when he was 17 and
admitted this has been weighing on him
for nearly half of his life quote this
doesn't bring me shame just a weight and
burden I have held on to for a long time
[Music]